shortly after Ludwick was crowned king
at the early age of 18 he got to work
sometimes he was busy planning three
castles at the same time he bought an
island in Lake chiemsee in order to
build a magnificent Palace on it cost
was not a factor Heron Kim's a palace
was an expression of his admiration for
french king louis the 14th but he didn't
intend heron Kim's a unlike Versailles
to be a center of power or focus for
court society lubick was searching for
the illusion of Anna dilek bygone world
and he was looking for solitude
the raccoon igloo prevents casino
Ludwick's been a total of ten days here
in the palace in late-september 1885 in
the dugûnan when it got dark thirty five
servants had to light all the candles in
the palace and I'm soon intros and after
that they all had to disappear so the
king was all alone in his palace allina
en cross another castle he had built for
himself alone was noise van-steen
clearly visible from many angles yet
unapproachable it's situated in the
foothills of the Alps and is the most
famous of all his castles neuschwanstein
represents a romantic interpretation of
the Middle Ages a fortified castle with
a singers Hall to pay tribute to the
times of chivalry yet Ludwik was also a
child of his times he loved technology
his castle had telephone lines
battery-powered bells for the servants
and running water but as with Harlan
chiemsee lubick didn't live to see noise
feinstein completed not far away lies
the only palace Ludwig was able to
finish Linda Howe ludic lived here for
quite a while and it feels more
accessible built in the Baroque style
and surrounded by a large Park and here
he could retreat to an artificial grotto
shortly after ludic died at an early age
under mysterious circumstances his
fairytale castle and palaces were open
to the public for all to enjoy